One of the mistakes that
people often make is to
only test their site's
performance on the desktop.
Because desktops are significantly
more powerful than mobiles,
it means you can miss performance issues
that only show up when on device's CPU,
memory or connectivity constrained.
What you want to do is where you can,
test on real devices.
If you have an Android device,
you can use the same Chrome DevTools
you know and love from your desktop.
So I can start it, interact, stop,
and you can see I got a timeline
that I can work with.
If you don't have an Android
device available,
you can check out
the instructor notes below for
how to use the emulation
settings in Chrome DevTools.
Remember though, that the performance
characteristics of simulators and
emulators are wildly
different to a device itself.
So while it's good for getting used to
the workflow, you'll need to test on
the device itself to make sure that you
don't have any performance issues there.
In the next video, Peter Lovis is
going to show you how you can use
Chrome DevTools with
your Andriod device.
If you already know, just skip ahead.